we wanted to kind of do something that
we've never done before the weekend is
ready to kick off the pepsi super bowl
55 halftime show in an
epic and unprecedented way
[Music]
it has been reported that you pumped
millions of your own dollars into this
performance and we now know that it will
come
entirely from the stand so can you tell
us three ways that you will innovate
since you won't have the traditional
stage
due to the covet and and for the safety
of the players and
the workers we kind of built the stage
within the stadium
and uh we're also using the field as
well but we wanted to kind of do
something that we've never done before
i'm not going to tell you anything else
because
you'd have to watch on sunday the 30
year old singer whose real name is abel
tezfay has never shied away from being
provocative with his art
he's been super committed to the
aesthetic of his latest album
after hours rocking suits and head
bandages at many recent performances
so will that carry over to the halftime
show performance
i definitely want to be respectful to
the viewers at home
i will still incorporate
some of the storyline it's a very
cohesive story i've been telling
throughout this era and throughout this
year so
the story will continue but definitely
we'll keep it
pg for the families and when it comes to
super bowl halftime shows of the past
the weekend says one stands out above
the rest
my favorite is definitely diana ross
1996.
she's just so glamorous and the show
just makes me smile and
she has a great exit with the helicopter
she lands in the middle of the field
grabs onto it and flies out into the
crowd into the clouds
it's like i wish i could have done that
i wish i thought of it
i don't think i have enough money to do
it to be honest super bowl 55 airs live
sunday february 7th on cbs and cbs all
[Music]
access